former Democratic presidential contender
Bernie Sanders tells CBS this morning he
believes the vast majority of his
supporters will back former Vice
President Joe Biden even though many
including Sanders former press secretary
say they won't in his first Network TV
interview since endorsing the
presumptive Democratic nominee the
Vernon the Vermont senator spelled out
the issues where he expects Joe Biden to
adopt a more progressive stance on day
one of my campaign what I said is that
if I lose I will be there to support the
Democratic nominee because it is
absolutely imperative that we defeat
Donald Trump who in my view is the most
dangerous irresponsible president in the
modern history in this country it's an
argument against Donald Trump but making
the argument for Joe Biden is a
different matter to defeat Donald Trump
to me and make sure that he is not
reelect 'add is enormous ly important so
if you want to make the point that Joe
Biden's views are not mine no kidding
I think everybody in America knows that
I made a little list of some of the
things that have been central to your
campaign and I'm hoping you can let me
know which of these you think could be
part of a Biden administration universal
health care is a biggie free college for
all canceled college debt national rent
control a ban on fracking a wealth tax
marijuana legalization a 50% reduction
in the prison population these are all
things you've campaigned on that it made
you popular Joe Biden doesn't support
any of them which do you see him moving
on well I think you will see him moving
on making public colleges and
universities tuition-free for families
earning less than 125,000 not where I
was I wanted more I think his views on
climate change are not my views but I
think he is prepared to invest many
hundreds of billions of dollars into
sustainable energies like wind and solar
and in the process create a whole lot of
jobs I think on health care he is not an
advocate of Medicare for all as I am but
I think he's prepared to compose with
some ideas has he promised you anything
well we have talked about a number of
issues and you will see those evolving
coming out I believe in the next we
months Joe Biden is gonna need every
vote that he can get how do you improve
on your 2016 record to make sure that
our 2016 record was a fine record think
I'm in this house right here I got a
couple of letters from Hillary Clinton
thanking me for the very strong support
that I gave her I did rally after rally
stayed up to say look the issue is that
the American people are gonna have to
make a fundamental decision I'm gonna
play a role in that do we come together
to defeat somebody who is a pathological
liar somebody does not believe in the
rule of law somebody who is prepared to
give massive tax breaks to billionaires
and ignore the needs of working families
or do we elect Joe Biden as president I
think the choice is pretty clear I
imagine you will be fundraising for a
job I you know you can we will decide on
what we're gonna do with fundraising all
I would say is that we're gonna do
everything that we can to make sure that
Donald Trump is not re-elected how do
you campaign in the midst of this
pandemic should there be conventions can
you have rallies in the late summer
maybe nobody can predict it the last
thing that we want to do is to do
anything which gets more people sick and
kills more people that is the last thing
that we want to do so I think that
whether or not there'll be a convention
remains to be seen I don't know nor does
anybody else when rallies will be taking
place when candidates will be able to be
out on the streets shaking hands and
talking to people face to face nobody
knows that
I think it's indisputable that this
virus has exposed how medically and
financially fragile many sectors of our
society are that's right in that tragedy
and our response to it do you think
society may reevaluate the need for the
policies you've been arguing for for 30
years now the answer is yes this
pandemic the economic collapse has
exposed the fragility of our health care
system and our economy in terms of
protecting working families that is a
lesson that I think many Americans are
going to learn from this we also asked
senator Sanders about other concerns
some supporters have including a set
assault allegation against Joe Biden his
accuser reportedly filed a police report
last week now claiming Biden assaulted
her in 1993 when she was working in his
Senate office published reports indicate
her story has changed over the years
Biden's campaign calls the allegation
quote untrue and says the alleged
incident quote absolutely did not happen
close quote
here's what Bernie Sanders had to say
about it one of your most important
allies Alexandria Kashia Cortes said
recently that she thinks it's legitimate
and relevant to talk about sexual
assault allegations against Joe Biden do
you agree I think it's relevant and to
talk about anything and I think any
woman who feels that she was assaulted
has every right in the world to stand up
and make her claims do you think that
should weigh significantly in the mind I
think that she has the right to make her
claims and get a public hearing and the
public will make their own conclusions
about it I just don't know enough about
it to comment further all right so as
you can see guys it was a really
wide-ranging conversation in addition to
all of those topics I also asked him
about Joe Biden's pick for
vice-president who that should be and
Bernie Sanders told me he'll leave it up
to Joe but he hopes that it'll be as
progressive a choice as possible yeah
we're all waiting to see what that's
going to be but I found Tony let's go
back to the first part of the interview
when you asked him about fundraising
I found his answer very interesting on
that it didn't sound like a yeah I can't
wait to get out there with or without
this pandemic did you take anything away
from that react from that answer the the
fact that he's not right now committing
to fund raising for Joe Biden tells me
that that might be a point of leverage
for him to try to get some of these
ideas that are not part of the Biden
platform into that platform before the
election